tu mi piaci
[Musica]
tanto Cas
ah tanto non è che sei questo grande
attore m Scusa la mia fidanzata Anita è
stata rapita e loro sono quattro
sospettati uno di loro l'ha rapita li
sottoporrò ad una serie di prove per
capire chi è il colpevole tra cui la
macchina della verità dobbiamo sbrigarci
perché non so dov'è Anita Provate anche
voi a scoprire che il col insieme a me
ho bisogno del vostro aiuto state
attenti a tutti gli indizi e guardate il
video fino alla fine così mi aiuterete a
scoprire chi è stato e a trovare Anita
Per prima cosa andiamo a conoscere i
sospettati tu chi sei ad esempio io sono
Alice La makeup Artist di Anita makeup
Artist quindi ti occupi di dolci cupcake
queste cose così Ma cosa hai capito Io
trucco Anita Sono molto preoccupata per
lei m è preoccupata questo lo
verificheremo E tu invece chi sei
Io sono Julie la fan numero uno di Anita
Infatti ho anche il suo nuovo libro La
città stregata Tra l'altro ne ho 13 di
suoi libri e una maglietta
personalizzata creata da me e sono
davvero tanto dispiaciuta perché lei è
scomparsa insomma mi manca moltissimo
sei la faan numero uno quindi potresti
essere stata tu a rapirla proprio perché
volevi averla tutta per te è vero È
questo il motivo ma no ma non mi
perderei mai tu non me la racconti
giusta E tu invece chi sei Beh Vitale
non ti ricordi di me Io sono chef
Gnocchetto chef Gnocchetto ma è quello
che mi ha rubito Nell'altro video Esatto
E tu che cosa ci fai qua dovresti essere
in calera Beh io ho scotato la mia pena
e adesso sono uscito ma non mi
permetterei mai di rapire Anita lui è
sospettato numero uno ha rapito prima me
Nell'altro video e adesso sta cercando
di rapire anche Anita non è così eh eh E
tu invece chi sei io sono Nicolas
fattoretti un grande attore di fama
internazionale e anche collega della
scuola di recitazione di Anita Ah quindi
un collega di Anita e questo fa di te il
perfetto candidato sei stato tu non è
vero io perfetto candidato Ma cosa dici
a me dispiace tantissimo che Anita non
si trovi più anzi sbrighiamoci a
trovarla Vi prego E adesso che abbiamo
conosciuto i personaggi iniziano le
indagini non c'è tanto da indagare
Secondo me sei stato tu come io Non può
essere io sono uscito solo per cucinare
Secondo me invece è stato lui Ma cosa
dici accusato da uno appena uscito di
galera E poi tu hai già rapito Vitale
non venir a raccontare queste cose a me
Guarda No sei stata tu tu eri più a
contatto con Anita la vedevi dietro le
quinte la truccava Eh non me la racconti
giusta non penso proprio caro Io penso
solo al mio lavoro Secondo me è stata la
signorina qui ma non è vero Io sono la
fan numero uno di Anita quella che ha la
sua faccia nella maglietta
e voli appunto per stare solo con lei
sei la più sospetta Non è
vero stato lui ma cosa diato da uno
appena uscito
di Ma qui ci sono delle tracce il
rapitore è sicuramente passato da qui
ragazzi ma dov'è andato Vitale era qui
Un secondo fa stai cercando di cambiare
il discorso allora sei stato tu per
forza Sì magari lui io l'ho detto Magari
è rapito nuovamente Vitale no E invece
sei stata tu per provare nuovi trucchi
Vero Basta adesso dobbiamo trovare Anita
chi se ne frega di chi è stato troviam
Ola senò non posso fare più le mie parti
a teatro sarò da solo come faccio adesso
Ahah le impronte finiscono qui questo
deve essere l'armadietto del rapitore
controlliamo e scopriamo che cosa c'è
dentro
Oh Guardate che cosa ho trovato questo è
un messaggio segreto che potrete
tradurre con l'alfabeto segreto che
trovate all'interno del libro La città
streg deve essere un indizio per capire
chi è il
colpevole Tanto non è che sei questo
grande attore m Scusa ma ti sei vista se
trucchi le altre persone come ti trucchi
tu guarda il lavoro è rovinato è proprio
una carriera davanti che finisce domani
come ti permetti io ho imparato a
truccarmi nelle più grandi accademie di
makeup al circo
grande Guardate che cosa ho scoperto
questa sembra la mascherina di un pilota
di aerei Avete presente i piloti di
aerei che si mettono la mascherina per
pilotare meglio ma no che cosa sto
dicendo avrebbe detto così Anita questo
sicuramente è di qualcuno che ha
problemi a respirare quindi il rapitore
ha dei problemi di respirazione Mi è
venuta un'idea per la prima prova
[Applauso]
verita questa basta basta Ma state
ancora litigando Ma questo finirà subito
non vi preoccupate perché scoprirò
presto Chi ha rapito Anita prima prova
prova di
ballo ma io non so ballare Peggio per te
allora prima prova gara di ballo e
l'ultimo che smette di ballare vince e
pronti
via ballo della Parella
bollente ricorda tanto la febbre del
sabato sera che interpretai an forza
ritmo sono la più brava Intanto in
realtà Io voglio scoprire chi è che si
stanca per primo e avrà il fiatone così
scoprirò di chi è quel
respiratore
sto Mi viene da piangere Se solo penso
che questo ballo l'avrei potuto fare con
Anita Ma
dov'è Se non avessi fatto la truccatrice
avrei sicuramente fatto la ballerina che
ritmo ragazzi sì oh quanti ricordi
questo era un ballo che mi aveva
insegnato mio padre chef spaghetto e ora
sto facendo l'impasto per la
pasta Ok secondo passo è
tagliarla terzo passo è prenderla e
buttarla nella
pentola sono Così fan di Anita che ho
inventato una danza in suo onore la
danza di Anita
[Musica]
Stories Guardate sto ballando con Anita
l'ho
salvata Purtroppo non è vero È solo il
poster che ho vinto in uno dei miei
libri però ballo lo stesso per
lei sembra che non si stiano stancando o
almeno io non riesco a capire che si sta
stancando di più quindi balli di coppia
adesso via Meno male che nella mia
grande carriera da attore Ho fatto anche
il ballerino Sango sei proprio
[Musica]
Deo
adesso voglio farlo io il caschetto Vai
caschetto caset perché mi prendi non
perché cado Ah Pensavo dovessi farti
cadere ma guarda veramente non ci ballo
più
[Musica]
meglio visto i cuochi sono bravissimi
sia a ballare che a cucinare ma comunque
neanche tu sei male Senti Giulia Ti devo
dire una cosa sì eh tu per me sei come
la pizza il sabato sera e cioè cioè che
sei tanto speciale per me e insomma Tu
mi piaci
tanto cosa è successo Julie stai bene
Giulia è caduta a terra senza fiato
forse appartiene a lei il respiratore
andiamo subito alla macchina della
verità
tu dici di essere la fan numero uno di
Anita Ma dimmi la verità ti è mai stata
antipatica No
assolutamente quindi ti sta antipatica
davvero Beh sì c'è stato un periodo in
cui mi stavo antipatica perché gli ho
scritto esattamente
148586 messaggi e email e lei non mi ha
mai risposto Però poi gli ho scritto un
commento su YouTube e lei mi ha messo un
mi piace e lì mi è ato tutto perché ho
capito che certo non può rispondere a
tutti i messaggi perché sono tanti però
fa di tutto per leggerli e sono ancora
la sua fa numero un Non potrei mai
rapirla mm sembra sincera però è stata
lei a cadere per terra con il fiot
quindi resta ancora sospetta seconda
prova prova di recitazione così
scopriamo Chi è il più bravo a recitare
o meglio a mentire prima di iniziare mi
sistemo il makeup ma lascia stare
abbiamo deciso di portare in scena aml e
Ofelia grande opera se ci fosse stata
Anita sarebbe stata ancora fatta meglio
ma mi tocca sostituirla con te iniziamo
Dai Dai tocca Signore ho qui con me i
vostri ricordi che da tempo volevo
ritornarvi Vi prego riprendete
non rifaccio Scusa non aspetta non
riesco entrare nella parte non io
pausa dato niente e per E per questo e
accompagnati pure da parole ESP spiranti
dal profumo di dolcezza da renderli
oltre mondo più preziosi quel profumo è
svanito tocca a me riprendetevi
a cuor gentile anche i doni più ricchi
si fan Povera cosa si mostra crudele e
basta però tocca a me Insomma sono un
Amleto il protagonista Fammi parlare un
po' mancava una frase sono io l'attore
Dai allora mostra Ecco senti qua
Ess Ah ho sbagliato
aspetta Essere o non essere questo è il
dilemma se sia più nobile L'arte di
soffrire colpi di fionda e darti d'
oltraggiosa fortuna o prender l'armi per
un mare di affanni Grazie grazie grazie
No Come no io sono l'attore Guarda come
l'hai fatta ma per Ma vai via Guarda non
ci sto più Meno male studi teatro Alice
è molto brava a recitare certo quel
Nicolas si mette sempre in mezzo e non
mi fa capire bene Oh Romeo Romeo Perché
sei tu Romeo Beh io non sono Romeo Io
sono chef Gnocchetto e io sono Giulietta
Romeo Romeo Perché sei tu Romeo Non lo
so sarà Perché i miei genitori mi hanno
chiamato così E comunque io voglio solo
entrare a mangiare un piatto di
spaghetti Mi ha rovinato la parte adesso
non posso più fare lo spettacolo tu sei
Romeo E poi cosa c'entrano gli spaghetti
Insomma stai rovinando tutto Sono
d'accordo basta non è possibile avete
rovinato il nome di Shakespeare che si
sta rivoltando nella tomba non si fa
così non si fa Tu cosa stai facendo E tu
Anche tu non si stai attenendo al testo
bisogna seguire il testo ma che uomini
di teatro siete insomma Mi viene da
piangere a guardarmi così
Scusate ma quello è proprio fissato con
il
teatro è pazzo in questa prova di
recitazione credevo che Nicolas sarebbe
stato più bravo ma Alice invece è molto
brava a recitare e quindi anche a
mentire m solo che Nicolas si mette
sempre in mezzo e non mi lascia capire
bene ma credo che interrogherò comunque
Alice sembra lei la colpevole quella più
brava a recitare e a mentire sei stata
la truccatrice di Anita Come mai non lo
sei più che cosa è successo Beh non è
colpa mia è stata lei a non volermi più
E per quale motivo Racconta un giorno
molto importante Anita doveva entrare in
scena e come al solito sono stata io a
truccarla ma per errore quel giorno è
uscito un trucco bruttissimo e quindi
tutti hanno riso di lei ma non l'ho
fatto
[Applauso]
posta Come hai potuto farle un trucco
così brutto Purtroppo a teatro c'erano
delle luci molto basse e in più sono
daltonica e quindi questo ha peggiorato
tutto a me dispiace tanto non l'ho fatta
apposta non volevo che Anita entrasse
così in scena una truccatrice daltonica
quindi che non riconosce i colori questo
la rende ancora più sospetta Ma passiamo
ora
ad Ma passiamo ora ad interrogare gli
altri sospettati mi mancano solo due
persone da interrogare e poi farò la mia
accusa chef Gnocchetto mi sembra che tu
provi dei sentimenti per Julie Ma sai
anche che Julie è la fa numero uno di
Anita e quindi che ti dà poche
attenzioni per questo Potresti averla
fatta sparire tu vero No no Ti sbagli Io
farei qualsiasi cosa per Julie vorrei
vederla felice sai adesso che sparite
lei non c'è più mi si spezza il cuore
per questo non posso essere stato io
sembra sincero però rimane comunque un
sospetto Nicolas tu che se maestro
Nicolas
prego maestro Nicolas tu eri nella
stessa scuola di recitazione di Anita
avete mai
litigato No assolutamente no andavamo
sempre d'accordissimo per quello voglio
che la troviate
subito e va bene Qualche volta abbiamo
litigato insomma la maggior parte delle
volte venivano date delle parti a lei
che volevo io Insomma sono un grande
[Musica]
attore quindi pensi che Anita non si
meriti quelle parti che ha a teatro No
no assolutamente Anzi se lo meriterebbe
che anch'io tanto vorrei fare il
protagonista e che diamine Guardate come
sono
teatrale dopo gli interrogatori e le
prove sono pronto a fare la mia accusa
scrivete nei commenti che è il colpevole
Secondo voi e ora iniziamo da chef
miocchi All'inizio pensavo fossi tu il
colpevole e che avessi fatto sparire
Anita per avere tutte le attenzioni di
Julie ma non avresti mai potuto farla
soffrire così Quindi non sei tu il
colpevole Uh meno male non ci volevo
tornare in prigione poi ho pensato fossi
tu Julie la colpevole così fissata con
Anita da farla sparire Perché non hai
mai ricevuto una sua risposta ma poi ho
capito che ci tieni davvero a lei e
quindi non avresti mai potuto farlo Non
potrei mai rapirla Io sono la fan numero
uno di Anita
m quindi
Alice il fatto che Anita non ti aveva
più chiamata per truccarla magari ti ha
offeso talmente tanto da rapire No no ma
è un motivo troppo assurdo per rapire
una persona quindi non sei
tu rimani inf fine tu Nicolas e io
maestro Nicolas No no Ma che dici tu che
durante la gara di ballo eri senza fiato
ma per non farti notare hai consigliato
tu a chef Gnocchetto di dichiararsi a
Julie
Ehi questo ballo romantico Non ti sembra
il momento di confidare tu amore Per Hai
ragione è proprio il momento Grazie ce
la farai
amico così che Julie distoglie le
attenzioni da te per non parlare poi
della prova di recitazione che non
sopportavi di essere più nel centro
delle attenzioni proprio come è successo
in tutti questi anni di scuola di teatro
con Anita non è così ma questo è un
grande pronto a me grande attore
internazionale Non avrei mai potuto
rapire Anita Insomma non sarebbe
cambiato niente per me e invece no
perché ho trovato questo nel tuo
armadietto
Eh un attimo era tutto sgualcito ho
dovuto ricomporlo vedi Ecco dove dice
che Anita sarebbe stata di nuovo la
protagonista di un nuovo spettacolo e di
la verità tu non potevi sopportare di
essere nuovamente un personaggio
secondario e quindi l'hai rapita per
prenderle la parte da protagon E va bene
Mi avete scoperto no ti ho scoperto mi
hai scoperto ma almeno almeno sono il
protagonista di questa
[Risate]
storia il protagonista Tu al massimo
puoi essere l'antagonista di questa
storia sei il cattivo come l'antagonista
Eh sì no no l'antagonista è sempre un
ruolo secondario no ha di nuovo vinto
Esatto basta Lasciatemi stare io non
c'entro niente quello è mio cugino Filip
Rondò Sì è stato lui a organizzare tutto
mi somiglia m
lasam sappiate che state togliendo al
mondo del teatro un grandissimo attore
come farò adesso senza recitare
Mannaggia sappiate che un giorno mi
[Musica]
vendicherò
n